for all the cyclic molecules we've dealt
with so far we've just drawn them as
rings for example for cyclohexane
cyclohexane we've literally just drawn
it as a hexagon so we've drawn
cyclohexane like that
now we know from the last several videos
that all of the bonds for a carbon don't
sit in the same plane if we take the
example of methane that's the simplest
example you have your carbon sitting in
the middle you'll have kind of a
hydrogen popping out like that another
hydrogen that's in the plane of the
screen another one that's behind the
screen and another one that is straight
up so you kind of have this tetrahedral
structure and in the case of methane you
have that 109.5 degrees on angles carbon
likes to form bonds of this shape it
won't always be 109.5 degrees it'll be
something close to it depending on what
the different atoms or molecules are
that it is bonded to so given that what
would a cyclohexane molecule actually
look like if we try to visualize it in
three dimensions so to think about that
let's think about these two bonds first
I'll try my best to draw it in one of
its three-dimensional shapes so those
bonds right there I will draw like that
and then this down here in orange I will
draw like this and then this up here in
magenta I will draw like that and then
let me see in let me see in purple I'll
do these two right over here and I'll
draw them like this so you have that and
like that it so hopefully makes clear
that over there is that end over there
this end over here is this end over here
and this this way that I've drawn the
cyclohexane is called
a chair configuration chair chair shape
and it might be obvious it looks like a
chair that's the back of the chair this
is where you would sit down on the chair
and like I guess the back of your calves
would go against here your knees would
sit on at some place like that that's
called the chair configuration now
another configuration that it could be
in is called the boat configuration the
boat and so if I were to put this exact
one in the boat configuration if I take
it from a slightly different
perspective if I'm looking at it kind of
head-on it would look something like
this in the boat in the boat
configuration make it would look like
this it would I want to use the purple
it would look like that
now the first thing you're probably
saying is Sal you said that the reason
why it looks like this is because carbon
likes to form these kind of tetrahedral
or this tripod shaped tripod shaped
bonds I don't see the tripod shaped
bonds either here or here let me draw
that boat a little bit
at least this end of the boat a little
bit better there you go
and let me and you say well I don't see
those that tripod shape over there and
to see the tripod shape you just have to
draw the hydrogen's so let me draw some
hydrogen's here so let me draw a
hydrogen here that will go that will go
straight straight down like this the
hydrogen that goes straight down over
here a hydrogen that goes straight up
over here straight up over here straight
down over here straight up over there
I've now drawn one hydrogen on every
carbon and now let me draw some
hydrogen's let me draw a hydrogen here
that goes let me draw a hydrogen here
that goes straight up over we're not up
really to the side over here so a
hydrogen there let me draw a hydrogen
over here that does the same thing so
those guys have their hydrogen's a
hydrogen right over here and then let's
see this guy needs his hydrogen's still
so it'll have a hydrogen that goes down
like that and the hydrogen that goes
like that and then this guy will have a
hydrogen that goes like that and when
you see it like this if you look at any
any one carbon on this molecule if you
look at any one carbon you can see that
it's forming the same tetrahedral shape
that it has a tripod at every one over
here you have that close to roughly 100
910 degree angle between each of the
constituents that are bonding
to the carbon now I've drawn the
different hydrogen's that are coming off
of these carbons in different colors and
I've done it for a purpose the ones that
are going straight up or straight down
we call those axial hydrogen's axial
axial hydrogen's and the ones I drew an
orange that are kind of going to the
side in some level we call these
equatorial equatorial equatorial these
are equatorial hydrogen's and there's
reason why it's useful to know that name
is when we talk about the different
configurations the different chair and
boats whether something is equatorial or
axial can change if this were to flip up
or vice versa and things like that we'll
talk more about that in the next video
and the reason why they called
equatorial is if you think about it and
sometimes hard to visualize this bond
right here is parallel to this bond
right over there and this bond right
over here is parallel to this it's
parallel the equatorial bonds are
parallel to some part of the Ring so
that one is parallel to that right over
there actually I should even I could
even color-coded that this well I don't
want to use that same color this is
parallel to this and this is parallel to
that and we can do it for all the
equatorial bonds so for example I don't
want to I'm running out of colors here
so this right here is parallel to this
and this and that over there so we could
keep doing it for all of them I could do
it one for the other set right here this
guy right here is parallel to that guy
over there I didn't quite draw it like
that but hopefully it makes the idea
clear and I'll do one more of these just
to show what's parallel to what this
bond is parallel to that so the ones
that are parallel to some part of the
Ring we're calling equatorial and the
ones that kind of jump out of the ring
that aren't parallel to any other part
of the Ring we're calling those axial
and the way I've drawn it here the
actuals are the ones that point up and
point straight up and point straight
down we can do the same thing on a boat
configuration now one question you might
ask is well there's these two
configurations both of these would
result in tetrahedra
we'll type shapes at each of the carbons
in fact let me draw it for you so we
would have so this axial hydrogen is
pointing straight down this one is
pointing straight down here these this
hydrogen is actually we're going to
point straight down because we've
flipped it up and then over here you
would have a hydrogen points straight up
and then one that's kind of pointing
down this gives the tripod there to have
the tripod over here you'll have to have
a hydrogen points a little bit like that
one that points a little bit like that
one that's pointing a little bit like
that along well you can kind of view it
along the same plane as this guy would
be parallel it's hard to see it in this
but he would actually be parallel to
that this guy would be out like this and
then this guy would have an axial
hydrogen and then he would have one
equatorial one just like that so you
could draw the tripod shapes and either
the chair or boat configuration but one
question is well you know what's what's
more stable that's actually one of the
main points of being able to visually
think about the three-dimensional
structure of any of these hydro any of
these hydrocarbons or in this case
cyclic cyclohexane so in this situation
we know and from past videos that all of
these carbons with their hydrogens
around on these bonds these have
electric electron clouds around them the
electron clouds are negative and so they
want to get as far away from each other
they want to get as far away from each
other as possible in this chair
configuration you have this carbon up
here this carbon the ch2 we could
consider it has two hydrogen's connected
to the rest of the ring it's as far as
possible from this ch2 as possible so in
that situation we have a lower potential
energy or it is a more stable more
stable shape or more stable
configuration in the both configuration
this ch2 up here is much closer to this
ch2 I mean that's really the main
difference between the two and they want
to get away from each other they want to
repel each other so this one will have
higher potential energy or it will be
less stable less stable less stable so
this is just a starting point of how to
visualize cyclic cyclic
hydrocarbons and we'll use this
information in the next video to think a
little bit more about maybe the the
different chair configurations that a
molecule could have and what could be
more stable in this situation in the
case of just cyclohexane the two chair
configurations are equally stable and
let me just touch on that a second so
you have well I don't have to actually
let me see
I won't copy and paste it I'll just
redraw the other chair configuration for
this guy actually let me just do it
separately over here because I've made
the colors here so confusing let me draw
to the same the same cyclohexane but in
two different chair configurations that
it could be equilibrium in so you could
have this one you could have this one so
this could be one chair configuration
and I'll draw it like this and then the
same hydrocarbon could be an e or the
same cyclohexane could be an equilibrium
with this other chair configuration that
looks like this that looks like this we
have a little more space here so it
looks like this let me do the pink goes
up like that like that let me make sure
I'm know I want to do it actually this
pink guy goes like this and then the mid
and then the blue guy is going to be
just like this so notice in this
situation this carbon up here is kind of
at the top of the chair and this carbon
is at the bottom and then they flipped
but these are equally stable
configurations but one thing to think
about is all of the axial guys on this
carbon here turned into equatorial on
this carbon and vice versa on the two
let me show it to you let me just draw
the hydrogen's on this carbon so if I
were to draw this hi this carbons
hydrogen's has an axial hydrogen and has
an equatorial hydrogen that would whose
bond would be parallel to that right
just like that and this guy would have
an equatorial hydrogen whose bond is
parallel to actually both of these guys
and an axial hydrogen and an axial
hydrogen but when it flips and I'm just
drawing those guys hydrogen's but when
this
structure flips like that what happens
well this hydrogen over here this
hydrogen over here goes into this
position and this yellow hydrogen over
here goes into this position so over
here it was equatorial and now it
becomes axial and now it becomes axial
in the same argument government can be
made over here this equatorial hydrogen
when it flips when this whole blue part
flips down now becomes axial now becomes
axial and this axial hydrogen when you
flip it down becomes equatorial it
becomes equatorial and you can actually
do that for all of the hydrogen's over
here you have an axial hydrogen axial
hydrogen once you flip it once you flip
it let's say you have an axial hydrogen
and then you have an and then you had an
equatorial hydrogen an equatorial
hydrogen when you flip it these two
equatorial hydrogen's become axial so
they become axial and then both of these
guys become equatorial so let me do that
in yellow both this guy and this guy
become equatorial so this and that
become equatorial they become parallel
to the other end and you could do it for
this these two hydrogen's as well so
that's another interesting to think
about it and this is really just
practice on visualizing what's going on
and when we when we visualize these
molecules in three dimensions